من السيارات إلى ناطحات السحاب ،
ترقى دبي بالتأكيد إلى لقبها هو
سوق الذهب في مدينة الذهب ويعود تاريخ سوق الذهب في دبي إلى
القرن العشرين وهو أحد أكبر
أسواق بيع الذهب بالتجزئة في العالم
على الرغم من انخفاض الطلب
على المجوهرات الذهبية في الإمارات العربية المتحدة.
محاصرًا بنسبة 25 في
المائة تقريبًا من التجارة العالمية والذهب ولكن
هناك مكان واحد في المدينة حيث يكون
مذاق الذهب على مستوى آخر هو
السابع والعشرون على وجه الدقة ، لذا فنحن في
الطابق السابع والعشرين هذا هو الذهب على
شريط 27 في الأيقونة  فندق برج العرب
وهذا هو كبير المختصين في الخلطات ، سوكيرا
فرناندو ، يعمل بالكثير من الذهب ، فليس من
المستغرب أن يداعبه البعض
عندما أعود إلى المنزل ، فأنا مليء بغبار
الذهب وعناصر الذهب بشكل أساسي قال صديقي
أنك تعلم أنني أرسم في  ليلة
هناك العديد من الأطباق الذهبية التي يجب تجربتها ،
لدينا مسحوق ذهب عيار 24 قيراطًا ، لذلك هذا
سائل ذهبي حقيقي ثم نصنع
الشوكولاتة الذهبية ، ثم لدينا
مطحنة الفلفل الذهبي ولديهم
الهدف النهائي باباجينا الجنون مثل
حسنًا ، يبحث هنا وفريقه باستمرار
عن طرق جديدة لاستخدام هذه
المادة الثمينة ، لذا يجب أن أتوصل كل أسبوع
إلى أفكار ذهبية جديدة
مشروبهم المميز هو العنصر 79
الذي حصل على اسمه من الرقم الذري للذهب ،
ويتكون من ثلاثة غير  - المرارة الكحولية
عصير فوار سائل من الذهب عيار 24
وقد انتهى بمكعب
من السكر يبدو جيدًا بالتأكيد لذا يجب أن يكون
مذاقًا رائعًا جدًا لنكون صادقين ،
فالذهب لا يضيف حقًا طعمًا
لمشروب إنه مجرد تأثير عاطفي
الشعور بالرضا على الرغم من أن الناس ما
زالوا على استعداد لدفع الكثير من أجل
هذا الشعور بأن تكلفة هذا المشروب تبلغ حوالي 40 دولارًا ، حيث
يقدم ما يصل إلى 700 جرام من الذهب كل
عام ، ومن المؤكد أن برج العرب
يساعد في تعزيز سمعة دبي باعتبارها
مدينة الذهب
[موسيقى]